everybody we've got to freak out about episode five so just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen it yet
We're almost done with the season
so if you're finding me for the first time be sure to subscribe to get everything there were so many bombs
atomic bombs dropped in this episode and
Gilly's was probably my favorite so list of Top 10 WTF and easter eggs from the books there were all kinds of
references going back to season 1 especially when Jon met Gendry for the first time. But let's start at the top of the episode
Daenerys sentencing Randyll Tarly and Dickon to death, so you have to feel bad for Dickon
but now you
understand why they had so many of those Jaime jokes, they want you to remember who he is and why he's important.
They wanted you to sympathize with them for a little bit.
I feel like it kind of didn't work like a lot of people are like
maybe he's the one that saved Jaime that probably would have made people sympathize with them more
but that wound up being Bronn.
You can't die until I get what's owed me only I can kill you but I really love the way they shot that scene though
Where she walks into the bottom of the frame just towers over
everyone just to show you visually with the camera
how much power she has if the giant dragon behind her didn't do the trick. So many great Tyrion moments here?
They're laying little bombs for each of the storyline like Littlefinger left a little bomb for Arya to find, Gilly dropped a big Rhaegar targaryen
Lyanna Stark bomb, so this is the writers
dropping a Tyrion-Daenerys bomb like she won't be the "Mad Queen" as long as she has someone really good to counsel her
Oh, don't worry
I'm not going to chop their heads off, instead they get incinerated to ash right before everyone.
There were a couple chuckles to be had with the way that Drogon screamed making everyone immediately
bend the knee, but you have to know that Randyll Tarly is a proud man
and I love the way he went out like a boss.
He lets Daenerys know exactly what he thinks of her, Tyrion, and the Dothraki.
So I'll understand if you kind of sympathize with his character because he was a great battle commander
but it's almost like they wanted it to be no out for that situation like he was never going to do what Daenerys wanted so
she would have seemed weak had she not burned them alive. And by the end of the episode, Samwell still doesn't know that
they're dead, the maester say that they never told them and Samwell never acknowledges it is there riding away from the Citadel.
But number nine up at Winterfell
we finally see that scene from the trailer where Bran wargs all the ravens to find out where the army of the dead is
An the Night King looks like he's able to break
Bran's control them so I would say they're relatively evenly matched in terms of power levels
So it'll be interesting to see if they have some sort of psychic battle before the end of the season because they're mostly concerned with
physical battles right now especially with Jon Snow's party that just made it north of the wall.
But I love the way they follow up in the Citadel, you kind of know the direction
this was headed earlier in the season where the maesters are meant to be this really learned, but very stuffy, and old stuck in their ways
organization and I know a lot of people have conspiracies about their plot to get rid of magic in the world
but that all just seems like way too much story for the show to actually handle
so this is mostly just about Samwell being really upset
they're not actually going to do something about this.
But if you caught it there was some really quick references from some of the other maesters where they're talking about the Drowned God
in other prophecies,
They referenced Jenny of Old Stones claiming to be
descended from the children of the forest. In the books she was married to a prince, Duncan Targaryen.
She got a prophecy from a witch in the woods that was another version of the prince who was promised
So it's like them saying the maesters got a version of the prophecy of the prince who was promised
it was kind of true in a previous time
but they didn't listen so the cycle perpetuated so that might have something to do with them breaking the wheel this time,
breaking the cycle of ice and fire. But they really just want you to hate these old masters like yeah
There's a prophecy that is probably true, you got it a long time ago,
you didn't believe then, meaning that we have to deal with it again today
But it's another way for them to continue to invoke the idea of the prophecy of the prince who was promised Jon Snow,
Daenerys Targaryen, and everything that people are talking about the last couple of episodes.
Lots of stubborn people in the episode. Even though Daenerys seems to listen to Jon Snow like just like the maesters are very stuck in their ways.
Daenerys seems very stuck in the way that she's going to deal with people. So you see Tyrion just sitting there
Oh, she didn't have any other choice like he's trying to rationalize it and he said "burning people alive"
And Varys is like, "Oh yeah,
we used to do that at the Red Keep, I used to offer up people to the Mad King, I tried to justify it in
my mind say that this isn't my fault that this is happening.". So there are a couple things
I'll try to address through the course of the video and one is the way they're trying to hype up Arya versus Sansa
which I think is a misdirect totally not going anywhere
And the other is Daenerys- Mad Queen also don't think that that's actually going to lead to anything
I think they just don't have a whole lot going on within each of these camps outside of the main plot and they want to
add all this extra drama to make it feel like it's
Justified spending all these extra scenes at Winterfell when really there's nothing happening at Winterfell besides Bran having visions of the Night King like right
now Daenerys is just sitting around waiting for Jon Snow to get back with the white they went to get for Cersei
so that everybody would come together during the armistice.
But number 7, smuggler as always Davos smuggles Tyrion into King's Landing.
These were probably some of the best scenes in the episode in all of season 7 so far
just because they're big payoffs, but Tyrion's line where he's like- "Last time
I was here, I killed my father with a crossbow." , and then finally Davos remembers his son Matthos
He hasn't mentioned him this whole time- "Last time
I was here you killed my son with wildfire."
But that Tyrion-Jaime scene next to the Jon Snow-Drogon scene is my favorite of the season so far,
just big mythology payoff for Jon Snow meeting Drogon
but it's a big character payoff for Tyrion and Jaime together the dialogue was better, the pathos
in Tyrion's voice, you start to get the idea that Jaime's coming around
but everybody's worried about how Cersei going to react to this. She doesn't believe in the army of the dead.
Daenerys has an idea, she wants an armistice, so I love the follow-up to that to the idea that Cersei
knew about all this was happening because of her little bird so I'll follow up with that in a second
But we have to talk about the Gendry reunion, so number 6, Davos finds Gendry with a shaved head
"Oh the lannister soldiers they don't recognise me. I didn't think that I'd find you
I thought that you'd still be rowing.", so was nice of them to reference the fandom like all the memes about
Gendry rowing so that is the writer sort of winking at you from behind the camera.
But before Davos can even get a word in edgewise, Gendry's like- "Bam. I'm ready to go, oh no
I don't have a sword I have something even better.", and whips out a
giant war hammer just like Robert's. So this isn't exactly like Robert's
but it's made to look as close as possible like it's meant to invoke that imagery especially once he meets up with Jon Snow.
The whole scene with Davos trying to convince the gold cloaks to go away was great
but I love the way that Tyrion comes slowly walking down
And it's just a way for them to show you how Gendry can move with the warhammer, like he just brains them on the spot
So that's why when they get to the Jon Snow meeting, he's like- Oh, yeah.
He can handle himself don't worry.
But number five the big Cersei bomb. So obviously she knew about the meeting the whole time and let it happen
"Don't you ever betray me again.", and reveals another big plot bomb dropped that she's pregnant with another child with Jaime.
He seems genuinely happy, but now you're like, Oh wait a minute does this mean he's not going anywhere?
I think it's another reason for him to not leave and I'm fascinated to see if this actually winds up happening in the books because
by this time in the story Jaime has long since left Cersei's company.
They haven't had sex in a long long time
So I feel like the whole purpose of this baby is just to blow up by the end of the season and make Cersei go
even crazier like it seems like she wants to meet with Daenerys, she's all about the armistice
so there's hope that they can come together to fight the army of the dead
But just think of how she'd react and lash out if something were to happen to that, baby
even if Daenerys had nothing to do with then she would just go off the rails
It's just something that's ready to blow up in everyone's faces like the GIlly bomb that was dropped. So number four
Davos introduces Gendry to Jon Snow so many great references to season one- I met your father
He's talking about the time when Ned Stark came looking into John Aaron's business to find out about Robert's bastards
I met your father when he came to Winterfell
They acknowledge the great things that they did together during Robert's rebellion and Gendry just seems really pumped up about going to fight the army
of the dead, he's like I can't sit this war out
I have to do something about this. It almost feels like a little bit of band service because there's been so many times that they've
referenced moments from Robert's Rebellion or big things like they keep talking about Rhaegar keep hinting it R + L equals J
They keep referencing Aegon the Conquerer
So this is just one of those big payoff moments like what was it like when Ned Stark and Robert Baratheon
fought together as young men during the war. We'll get to see a version of that in the next episode
I love that Tyrion scene with Jorah where he gives him the coin that was from back in season 5 that was a long time ago
but really we got to talk about the big Gilly bomb, so number three- Gilly is a
human wiki for facts and just starts reading up things- how many windows in the great sept or there none now? Oh?
Yeah, you know you're right. There's this maester, he recorded everything it turns out
he recorded this "annulment" between someone called Rhaegar in
someone else down in Dorne while he was also getting him married to someone else.
So this is about as obvious as they can be as a way to tell you that Jon Snow
is not a bastard which you probably got a sense for when Missande was asking them
what is a bastard I have no concept of that where I'm from and Jon says
It's because my mother and father were not married, so this is one their confirmation that R plus L equals J
But also that they were married when it happened meaning that Jon Snow now has the most legitimate claim to the Iron Throne
Meaning that that plot bomb could blow up in anyone's face whenever they want
But I don't think that he's going to find out this season
And I don't think that Daenerys is either. Samwell didn't even sound like he was listening to Gilly when she said that
So Gilly might be the one to blurt that out
But I still think that Bran is going to be the one to tell him about his parents
So you have a couple different characters now that together have the information
that proved that Jon Snow now has the strongest claim to the throne
But if you're wondering, why his claim is stronger than Daenerys is, because she's his aunt it's because of primogeniture
So it means that the crown prince who had the strongest claimed of the throne
previously Rhaegar, when he dies or he died his entire estate
meaning all of his titles and his claim to the throne passed directly to his oldest living male heir
jumping over any other family members
So just because Daenerys was the sister of the next king of westeros it means that the succession
passes her over in favor of Jon. So again
we just had to reiterate that Jon Snow does not care about being king, he does not want the Iron Throne
So I don't think it's going to wind up being a very big thing
But it is a very huge confirmation so we can freak out about it in the comments
But as for him meeting Drogon for the first time obviously you see that moment
recognition in Drogon like he sniffs him he can sense that he's a Targaryen-- is a really convenient way to show you how they're
acknowledging Jon Snow's lineage and sets up future connections with the dragons meaning that yes
I totally think that Jon Snow will ride a dragon before season 8 is over
But I do not think that it's going to happen this season
I think this season is all about moving the chess pieces around and explaining why that's necessary, so you learn about Jon
Snow's heritage to inform why it's important that he be connected to Daenerys so that they can fight the war for the dawn
But I think they're leaving some of that big payoff for season 8 like Jon
Snow riding a dragon
feels like one of the biggest things the show could do they're definitely going to save that for the final season and
what dragon would he ride? What about the one that's named after his father?
Rhaegar. So you can let me know in the comments, Jon Snow rides a dragon which one does he ride first, does he ride Drogon
with Daenerys or does he ride Rhaegar by himself?
But number two obviously they dropped that big Arya bomb
Littlefinger proves that he's not completely incompetent he usesArya skills against her to try and create some more chaos inside Winterfell
Maybe to stall for time. You wonder what his game is, he wants Sansa
so that he can get to the Iron Throne she needs control of Winterfell, so if Arya is fighting with her
maybe that would just keeps Sansa
busy for the time being maybe that's his only endgame at this point because he still needs Sansa
so he doesn't want Arya to kill her
But the way, they're playing it up in that promo for the next episode makes it sound like Arya definitely wants to kill Sansa
But again, I don't think that's going anywhere
I think it's just hyping up drama
where drama doesn't exist and they'll both turn against Littlefinger quickly after that once they find out what he's been doing
And even add to that that she was forced to write that letter during season 1 by Cersei and everyone else
so it's not something that she believes she was just forced to write it, and then that was the end of it
she probably doesn't even remember until Arya confronts her with it. So number one of course the last big payoff
Jon Snow's party arrives at East Watch, and you have all these amazing reunions.
This is also one of my favorite scenes of the episode where they turn up Tormund is
hilarious as always- which queen is it that you want the help of the one with the dragons or the one that has sex with
her brother. Then Gendry recognized the brotherhood, Tormund remembers Jorah's father- he was chasing us down
So they just want to show you that everybody has a reason to hate each other
But then they come to their senses the gate opens and they walk into the wall of
whiteness so metaphorically into the mouth of madness. It's going to be fun. So obviously big action episode next week
there's only two episodes left
I believe both of the episodes are longer than an hour so it's going to be amazing
Leave all your requests for bonus videos in the comments below, but let me know like what was your favorite moment?
Which reunion was your favorite? There's a lot of big payoffs and even though they are speeding through stuff, it was a solid episode
Probably most surprised by the Cersei baby.
Just because you know that she's not long for this world like she's got to die at some point even if you don't believe in
the Valonqar. She's very clearly being presented as the
antagonist for the season like of all the bad people next to the Night King, she's the worst so it's like oh my God now
She's pregnant.
So of course it's going to end spectacularly bad for everybody involved.
What'll happen next is I'll post my trailer video in the morning for episode 6 then I'll post new Rick and Morty
Congratulations to the latest Giveaway Winner- Stephen Stapleton
Please private message me on the back end of my channel so I can get your contact details
You can click here to learn all about the Children of the Forest and the White Walkers
symbols from last week's episode and you can click here for my episode 4 video. Thank you so much for watching, everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight.